تظاهرات الليليه في كرمنشاه وكردستان وحرق
صوره ترمز للحرس الثوري في داسفول
الشماليه الاحواز
نه
يقول ان القوات الروسيه تخطط لامر غامض في
الجنوب
على جهود ملاحقه داعش وطارده امن المنطقه
للخطر
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
سنبدا من ايران حيث انطلقت تظاهرات
الليليه في محافظه كرمنشاه ضد النظام
الايراني فيما نفذ القوه الامن استعراض
للقوه في كردستان في محاوله لترهيب
المحتاجين
صوره ترمز للحرس الثوري في تزفول الشماليه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
وصل الرئيس الفرنسي الى الولايات المتحده
في زياره او زياره دوله تستمر ثلاثه ايام
يلتقي خلالها خصوصا نظيره الامريكيه جودا
ويعمل الرئيس الفرنسي في ان تسمى هذه
الزياره في دفع مساعيد دبلوماسيه رامي
في اوكرانيا ودفاع عن وجهه النظر الفرنسيه
قال الرئيس الاوكراني
الوضع على خط المواجهه لا يزال الصعبا حيث
تحاول القوات الروسيه التقدم في منطقه
دومباز وخاركه
لا يزال المحتلون يحاولون التقدم في منطقه
دوناتس والحصول على موطئه قدم له في منطقه
لوكانز والانتقال الى منطقه خاركه انهم
يخططون لشيء ما في الجنوب
وقد خلل فانتاكون ان القوه الروسيه تعتمد
على القصف الجوي بسبب تعثر حمله موسكو
البريه على اوكرانيا وتحدث مسؤولون
عسكريون امريكيون عن استمرار مساعده طهران
لموسكو وعن وجود مستشارين ايرانيين على
الارض واكد ان الاولويه حاليا تتمثلوا
بمساعده اوكرانيا على مواجهه الهجمات
الصاروخيه والمسيرات اضاف مسؤولون امريكي
المساعده الامريكيه لاوكرانيا بلغت تسعه
عشره مليار دولار
قال وزير الخارجيه الاوكرانيدي ميترو
كوليبا ان بلاده تحتاج الى انظمه دفاع جوي
لحمايه بنيتها التحتيه كما اكد كوليبا
خلال لقائه مع الامين العام لحلف الناتو
يانسون بريك في رومانيا على ضروره توفير
مولدات ومحلويات لتوفير ظروف المعيشيه
لائقه للاوكرانين
ونحتاج الى محولات ومولدات تمكننا من
استعاده طاقتنا وتوفير ظروف المعيشيه
اللائقه للناس اما بالنسبه لانظمه الدفاع
الجوي فستمكننا من حمايه البنيه التحتيه
من الضربات الصاروخيه الروسيه وهي
بالتاكيد قادمه وللاسف هذه الحقيقه التي
يجب الاستعداد لها
عشان نسى وسكرايكس ههه مع حاكم منطقه
كورسك الروسيه رومان ستروفي
star. القوات الاوكرانيه بشني حوالي 10
هجمه او 11 10 هجمه على المنطقه وقد قصفت
خلالها محطه كهرباء مما تسبب في انقطاع
الجزئيا لتيار الكهربائي في مقاطعتي صوتا
وكورنيفو اللاتيني تقعان على الحدود
الشماليه الشرقيه لاوكرانيا
واحد تحت الصفر هذه هي درجه الحراره في
الفتره الحاليه في كياف وهذا هو الوضع في
انحاء من اوكرانيا اما الاوكرانيون فقد
انتشرت لهم الصور وهم يبحثون عن مصدر لدف
في المخاطر والمكتبات العامه
الشتاء يعقد الامور في الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا وعلى عده مستويات لوجسيا سيصبح
من الصعب نقل القوه والعداد في الاراضي
المغطاه بالثلوج والوحل وبالتالي سيتعطلوا
اي مجهود تعبوي
مروحه من شانها ان تجبر القوات الروسيه
والاكرانيه على تثبيت مواقعها الدفاعيه
وتعزيز ما تعرف بحرب الخنادق حرب يتم
تركيز فيها على القصف الصاروخي والمدفعي
وعلى استخدام المسيارات التي تستخدم
الذكاء الاصطناعيه لبلوغ اهدافها
ولهذا استبقت القوه الروسيه الشتاء
باستهداف محطات الطاقه وشبكات توزيع
الكهرباء الاوكرانيه
لتحاول خلقه بين الشعب الاوكراني وقيادته
السياسيه كما اشارت له صحيفه الجارديان في
ملف خاصته لتاثير الشتاء على الحرب لكن
هذه المره يبدو انك فتى الشتاء راجحه
للطرفين الروسي والاوكراني معا ف كلاهما
لديه خبره في اداره هذا النوع من الصراعات
الجيش الاوكراني يسترد اراضيه كانت تحت
السيطره الروسيه وبالتالي قطع خطوط
الامداد عن شبه جزيره القرم موقفا بذلك
ايه تقدم كانت القوه الروسيه تنوي القيام
به
ومنذ بدايه الحرب وثقت منظمه الصحه
العالميه اكثر من 700 هجوم على مؤسسه صحيه
واذا اخذ بعين الاعتبار تاثر بنيه الطاقه
الاوكرانيه فان المستشفيات ستعجز عن العمل
بكامل طاقتها فلا شيء سيعمل ابتداء من
اقسام العنايه المركزه انتهاء بالمشارح
مرورا بقاعات العمليات
الجراحيهم بحساسيه الموقف اتفق اعضاء حلف
شمال الاطلسي في القمه المنعقده في
رومانيا على زياده دعمهم خلال فصل الشتاء
عبر ارسال مولدات الكهرباء والوقود
ومضادات الطائرات المسيره ومعيدات لحمايه
من البرد لدعم صمود الاكران العربيه
قال المستشار الالماني والله عرض بلاده
ارساله انظمه بيتريوتس المضاده للصواريخ
الى بولندا لا يزال قائما على الرغم من
اقتراح وارسو بان يتم توجيه الانظمه الى
اوكرانيا بدلا من ذلك اقتراح بولندا لقياس
استجابه فاترا من جانب برلين حيث يشعر
البعض بالقلق من ان نشر صواريخ باتريوت في
اوكرانيا قد يجر روح الفشل الاطلس الى
الانخراط بالصراع بين روسيا واوكرانيا وقد
قال خبراء عسكريون ان التدريب على الانظمه
شديده تحقيق قد يستغرق سنوات ايضا ما يعني
انه لن يلبي الاحتياجات الفوريه
تواجهوا الولايات المتحده خلال الايام
والاسابيع المقبله تحديين الاول اضراب سكك
الحديد وثاني هو مساعدته اوكرانيا في
مواجهه روسيا ريزو وبعدين اجتمع بي زعماء
الكونغرس في محاوله لحل الخلافات فيما هدد
جمهوريون بمزيد من الرقابه على خطط بيضه
انها ستستمر في تقديم هذه المساعده الرئيس
يوم الثلاثاء للتاكيد على ان لدى
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين خطاطا للتشريع
خلال الاسابيع المقبله
معلومات لتمويل الحكومه
والحرب في اوكرانيا وكل المسائل الخلافيه
والمهمه وسنجد ارضيه مشتركه وهذا املي لان
الامريكيين يريدوننا ان نعمل معا هناك
خلافات بين الرئيس الديمقراطي وزعماء
الكونجرس الجمهوريين حول قضايا داخليه
كثيره وسيكون التوفيق بين الزعماء
الحاليين امرا ضروريا لكن موضوع المساعدات
لاوكرانيا يبدو مؤثرا نظرا لابعاده الضخمه
دوليه
تعمل في القرن لكن الاوكرانيين لا
يستطيعون اسقاطها الا اذا امتلكوا مضادات
بعيده المدى المدارس
تعطيهم هذه الاسلحه لو اعطيناهم هذه
الاسلحه سيفوز الاوكرانيون والاساره
المعركه طويله وحرب استنزاف
يبدو من كلام الزعماء الجمهوريين انهم
يطالبون الاداره الديمقراطيه بالمزيد من
المساعدات لاوكرانيا لكنهم يريدون ممارستا
رقابه اكثر على الاداره الحاليه
في الغالب العربيه
250 مهاجرا كانوا يحاولون عبور المانشيلا
بريطانيا
في الوقت الحالي تستمر داعش لقد خللنا عدد
الدوريات المشتركه وكما ذكرت في بيان
الاسبوع الماضي مازلنا نشعر بقلق عميق اذا
التوتر المتصاعد في شمال سوريا والعراق
وتركيا لذلك نحن نحث على ضبط النفس وسط
التوترات في هذه المنطقه ان استمرار
الصراع وخاصه الغزو البري من شانه ان يعرض
للخطر المكاسب التي حققها العالم بشق
الانفس ضد داعش وسيؤدي الى زعزعه استقرار
المنطقه في المقابل اننا نعترف بمخاوف
تركيا الامنيه المشروعه فيما يتعلق
بالاعمال الارهابيه التي حدثت داخل حدودها
انا مشاهدينا الى الموجز الرياضي مع
الزميل محمد القناص
[موسيقى]
ره كبيره
وصلهم الى كاس العالم و اخرها 2018 المغرب
همم
الطريقه الايجاز يدير فيها المنتخب انا
اشوف ان عقلانيه ومنطقيه همم اللاعبين
اللي يلعبوا معها في التصفيات الى الان
متمسك فيهم واا لغه الحوار معهم همم
يعني احس انها مرتاحه لها هو كمدرب
اخبروا الرياضه حياكم الله يعود المنتخب
السعودي الى ساديو سهيل الذي شهد الانتصار
التاريخيه امام الارجنتين هذه المره لخوض
المواجهه الحاسمه امام المنتخب المكسيكي
الاخضر سيصل هذا اللقاء وهو يواجهه معضله
الغيابات
شراحيلي لاننا سيتقدوا خدمات محمد البريك
الاصابه وعدد الاله المالكي بسبب الايقاف
وهو الذي كان فقد خدمات القائد سلمان
الفرج والمدافع ياسر الشهراني الاصابه في
مباراه الارجنتين
واكد اندرس غواردادو نجمه منتخب المكسيك
جاهزيته لمواجهه السعوديه ويعوده بورداته
الذي يشاركه للمره الخامسه في المونديال
على اي تواجد في تشكيلته امام الاخضر
وفي مباراه اخرى يبحث فيها الطرفان عن
تاكيد احقيتهما وحج مقعد في دوري 16 يلتقي
منتخب الارجنتين
مباريات المجموعه الثالثه ايضا المنتخب
الارجنتيني يحتاج الى الفوز لضمان التاهل
بشكل مباشر او سيكفيه التعادل بشرط عدم
فوز المنتخب السعودي وسيكون هدف ميسي
والرفاقه والانتصار بكل تاكيد لاثبات
جدارتهم بالترشح اللي لقب كاس العالم
بالمقابل سيحتاج منتخب بولندا الى التعادل
كعقل الاحتمال للوصول الى الدوري المصري
وعلى استاد المدينه التعليميه يتشبث منتخب
تونس باله في التاهل الى دوري المقبل
عندما يواجه حامل اللقب المنتخب الفرنسي
ويملك نسور قرطاج نقطه واحده فيما ضمن
منتخب فرنسا التاهله الى الدور الثاني
اليوم مازال عنها
وما يعرفوه
حتى شيء مستحيل في كره القدم
كل الثقه وكل التحفيظ مش حقه نتيجه
ايجابيه ان شاء الله يكونوا موافقين اهم
شيء المعركه
بخير تحدثت مع بنزيما بعد مغادرته ووضعه
سيء ويحتاج الوقت من اجل الشفاء مواجهه
تونس لن تكون سهله سيلعبون بكل قوه من اجل
تحقيق الفوز والتاهل لكننا سنخوض المباراه
بجوده كبيره رغم ضمان تاهل الى دور السته
عشر
وهو في المجموعه ذاتها يسعى المنتخب
الدنماركي ويحتل الاسترالي المركز الثاني
بثلاث نقاط بينما تحتل الدنمارك المركز
الثالث بنقطه متقدمتان على النسور قرطاج
اهداف
[موسيقى]
على منتخب وانجلترا الى دوري 16 في صداره
المجموعه الثانيه بعد ان ظفر بدرب المملكه
المتحده على حساب الجار ويلز بثلاثه اهداف
من دون مقابل شوط المباراه الاول انتهى من
دون اهداف
الثاني سجل ماركوس راشفورد الهدف الاول
لمنتخب بلاده من ركله حره بعدها بدقيقه
اضافه الهدف الثاني للمنتخب الانجليزي
[تصفيق]
اما الامريكان فحسموا التاهلات ثانيا في
المجموعه بفوزهم على منتخب ايران بهدف من
دون مقابل ضمن المجموعه ذاتها الهدف سجله
كريستيان بيلزيتش قبل نهايه الشوط الاول
في مباراه نالت كثيره من الانتباه حول
العالم باسباب غير رياضيه لترفع امريكا
التي ضربت موعد معه هولندا في الدوري
المقبل رصيدها الى خمس نقاط خلف انجلترا
مجمد رصيده ايران عنده ثلاث نقاط لتود
بدوره ضامنا منتخبه هولندا تاهله الى
الدوري المقبل عن المجموعه الاولى بعد
فوزه على نظيره القطري بهدفين من دون
مقابل في ختام المباريات المجموعه احرزاء
كودي جاك بو هدفه هولندا الاول في الدقيقه
الخامسه والعشرين قبل ان يضيف فرانك دي
يونج الهدف الثاني في الدقيقه التاسعه
والاربعين يرتفع رصيد المنتخب هولندا الى
70 نقاط تصدر بها قمه المجموعه الاولى
بينما بقي رصيد وقطر خاليا من النقاط بعد
ما تلقى منتخبنا الخساره الثالثه
ورافق منتخب السنغال الهولنديين كثاني
المجموعه الى الدوري المقبل بفوزه بهدفين
مقابل هدف على الاكوادور في ختام دور
المجموعات على استاد خليفه الدولي سجل
للسنغال اسماعيل الاسعار من ركله الجزاء
في الدقيقه الرابعه والاربعين واذل
الاكوادور نتيجه عبر كايسيدو في الدقيقه
الثامنه والسين قبل ان يهدي القائد كاليدو
كوليبالي طريقه السنغال الهدف الفوز
والعبور في الدقيقه 70
نقاط
دوري عنده 40 في المركز الثاني اودعت
[تصفيق]
كانت هذه ابرز واخبار المونديال شكرا لكم
على حسن المتابعه يا امان الله
[موسيقى]
يعني بصراحه بيلعبوا عندهم يعني البنيه
الجسمانيه قويه رغم انكسار المكسيك ولكن
زي ما ردوا
طيب الذكر
بسرعه في الالتحام غير يعني غير شوف قصير
بس انه يطلع معك بتجنن حتى في الاصدقاء ما
شاء الله يعني
همم يعني احسن طريقه معاهم
تلعب بحظر بصراحه لانه صراع والتناقلون
الكبار بسرعه يعني
[موسيقى]
مابلي مرض الالسايمر الذي تنتجه شركه اي
اس اي اليابانيه وشركه بايجن الامريكيه
نجح خلال تجارب السريريه في بطاقه تدهور
المعرفي والوظيف لدى المصابين بالمراحل
المبكره من المرض وهو ما يحتمل ان يكون
فوزا نادرا في هذا المجال
[موسيقى]
اعلنت السلطات الفرنسيه انقاذ 249 مهاجرا
كانوا يحاولون عبور المانش من الجانب
الفرنسي الى الجانب البريطاني وقالت
السلطات انها اطلقت خمس عمليات لانقاذ
مجموعات المتفرقه من المهاجرين ابحرت من
السواحل الفرنسيه باتجاه بريطانيا
امريكيه مؤسس جماعه حراس القسم المتطرفه
على هجوم العام الماضي او في هجوم العام
الماضي
خطط لاستخدام القوه لمنع تصديق رسميا على
فوزين في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
اعلنا حاكم فلوريدا الجمهوريه ارون
ديسانتشيز ان او ديسانتس عفوا ان التهديد
الذي اطلقته شركه ابل بحجم منصه تويتر من
متجر التطبيقات الخاص بها عقب مخاوف مشان
خطه الى ماسك تعديل محتوى الموقع يتنفى مع
ما تدعيه الشركه باحترام حريه التعبير وقد
اتهم ديسانتس شركه ابل بممارسه الرقابه
وخنقي اراده المواطنين الامريكيين
ختام ودينا اسرائيل
كردستان وحرق صوره ترمز للحرس الثوري في
دازفول الشماليه الاحوال
غامضا في الجنوب
البنت جواني يحذروا من تاثير العمليه
التركيه البريه المتوقعه على جهود ملاحقه
داعش وتعريضي امن المنطقه للخطر
اشكركم حسن المتابعه مشاهدينا الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]